MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So welcome today to
"Chefs at Google."
We have my pleasure to present
Taylor Boetticher and Ryan
Harris from The Fatted Calf
in Napa and San Francisco.
And they're going to do a Cuban
sandwich for you guys today,
and then a little demo on the
butchering of this half a hog
we have over here.
And then we'll have a
little Q&A after it's over.
So please, stick around.
Have a little bite to
eat, and enjoy yourselves.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Hello.
Thank you so much for coming.
We really appreciate it.
Yeah, we are from The
Fatted Calf Charcuterie,
and we always like to start
our demos with a little snack,
because who doesn't like snacks?
So one of the recipes that
I'm going to demo today
is the Cuban, which is one of
our takes on a classic Northern
Italian porchetta.
It's the recipe that's
on the cover the book.
It looks like just about
everybody has a copy.
The Cuban-- hi.
This is a riff on traditional
Northern Italian porchetta,
like I said.
It's seasoned with
cumin instead of fennel.
It's got orange zest
instead of lemon zest.
It also some smoked paprika,
a little bit of Allspice,
garlic, and some
chopped oregano too.
So the sandwiches that
we're making for you,
they have a little
bit of the Cuban roast
that we've already
smoked and then sliced.
And we've got some ham on there
too, some bread and butter
pickles, and some red onion,
as well as a little aioli.
So we'll be finishing
those up, and we're
going to pass those around.
And then I'm going to demo the
different cuts that we usually
take from a half a hog.
This one came from
the Stone Valley
Ranch, which is up by Chico.
It's one of three or four
farms the we will work with
to get our pork from.
Very tasty stuff.
It's certified
organic Berkshire.
We're going to talk about
different ways to cut pork.
Depending on what your
final desired outcome is,
I will talk a little
bit about husbandry.
We'll talk about seasoning.
Good, basic cutting techniques.
Things like that.
And of course, we'll answer
any questions you have as well.
Again, so thank you for coming.
And I hope you all still have
room for a little sandwich.
You like?
Oh, good.
Our pleasure.
Of course, thanks for having us.
AUDIENCE: Did you
guys make the pickle?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Yeah.
We made the pickles.
Everything that's on
there except for the buns.
Jason took care of the buns.
AUDIENCE: Do you sell
pickles in the shop?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: We do.
Yeah, absolutely.
Thank you.
No, that's fine.
Great.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Well, something that's
seemingly so simple
can be a thing of beauty.
It all comes down to
the little attention
to detail that makes a
difference between good meat,
beer, wine, cheese,
programming, whatever.
OK.
So now, onto the guest of honor.
This is the left half of
an organic Berkshire hog,
like I said, from the Stone
Valley Farm up by Chico.
And there are many, many
different great things
you can get off of
a whole half hog.
If you're going to take on
something like this at home,
I highly recommend
getting some friends.
Getting a good work table.
Making sure you've
got all your gear.
What we deem pretty crucial to
cutting pretty much anything,
whether it's lamb,
or beef, or pork,
you're going to want a
good, decent boning knife.
Usually, I don't advocate
spending more than $30
on a boning knife.
Because we're
pretty hard on them.
We're going to be working
right next to bone, hitting
on the steel pretty frequently.
And then, you want
something also
that isn't so thick that
it won't take and hold
a really good edge.
So I usually use
Victorinox or Forschner.
Whatever's comfortable for you.
I also don't like boning
knives for this kind of job
that are too flexible,
because they can slip,
and you don't want that.
So beyond the boning knife,
a good Ali-Baba-like cimeter.
Something good and long
that you can really
get through really
long cuts with.
And then a bone saw.
Those are really the only
tools you really need.
So I'm just going to
lay out exactly what cut
comes from where.
And then I'm going to show you
a few basic boning techniques
and talk about different cuts.
Different ways of cutting.
The way that we cut
pork in this country
is very different than the
way they cut it in France,
the way that they
cut it in Italy,
the way they cut it in Mexico,
China, everywhere else.
But I'm going to
be demoing, pretty
much, it's a very
traditional Italian way.
We're going to take
the hind leg off.
Show you how to cut that for
prosciutto, which is, again,
pretty traditional Italian.
Hi.
Great cut.
We're going to take
the shoulder off also.
I'm just going to show you a few
different ways you can cut that
into roast.
There's also some
different chops
you can take out of the
shoulder, which are really nice
also.
One of our more popular cuts
we do at The Fatted Calf
is a shoulder rib chop that's
seasoned with a little salt,
and garlic, and fennel pollen.
It's a great cut.
We got the fore-shank,
the trotters,
is where ossobuco and brine
and smoked ham hunks come from.
So the trotter is really good
for adding gelatin to tureens,
and adding just good
umami and soul power
to braises and things
like pata beans.
Things like that.
And then we've got, of course,
the interior, the middle here,
as it's poetically named.
That comprises the
loin, the belly,
which is obviously where
bacon and panchetta come from.
Great cuts.
And then we're going to talk
about the tenderloin, and also
the rest of these ribs.
This is the cut that we're going
to be taking out and de-boning
to make our Cuban.
So the first thing
I like to do is
to just kind of get a good
idea about where we're
going, what we're
looking at, by taking out
all this interior fat.
This is the fat that
surrounds the kidney.
It's also called leaf lard.
This is the baker's best friend.
This is really good
for things that you
want to puff up, like
pie dough, biscuit
dough, things like that.
You grind and render this
with a little bit of water,
and then strain it.
It'll hold really well in your
fridge for quite a long time.
And one of the key
tenants of charcuterie
is to use everything
and not waste anything.
That goes doubly for fat.
So the first thing
we like to do is
to just start to make
it into smaller pieces.
As of right now,
we've got a split hog.
We're going to separate this
in the three prime cuts.
We're going to take our hind
leg off for the the fresh ham.
We're going to take
our shoulder off.
And that's going to
leave us with the middle.
So the first thing we like to
do is to take the shoulder off.
And to do that,
what we usually do
is we separate it in between
the fourth in the fifth rib.
And then we're going to
saw through this backbone.
Sometimes depending on the age
and the breed of the animal,
the shoulder blade will be
either solid bone, which we'll
need to use the saw
for, or it'll just
be softer cartilage, which
we can use, as I call it,
Ali-Baba.
That'll get through it.
So again, right here there,
the first rib can kind of hide,
so you have to get
in there and find it.
I'm just going to go one,
two, three, and four.
And in between
ribs four and five,
we're just going to put our
knife right through the middle,
lift it up just to make sure
we're all the way through.
And again, kind of like
with the shoulder blade,
sometimes the breast
plate can be solid bone.
The thing you want to keep
in mind with tools like this,
the bone saw, you only want
to use for bone, because it'll
really tear the hell out of any
muscle you try and cut it with.
So if it's not happening
with the knife--
and you'll be able to
tell once you're through.
Just like that.
So now we take Ali-Baba
and just finish that cut.
And we're going to go all the
way back up to the backbone.
Now, we're going to
pick up our bone saw.
Go through there again.
[SAWING]
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: That looks
like an accident waiting
to happen.
[SAWING]
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: OK.
So we're through the backbone.
And again, we're going
to follow that same cut.
And we're through.
OK.
So now, we've got
that piece taken off.
That's starting to look a
little bit more familiar, right?
You can see the pork
chop right in there?
That's where our rib chops
start, right in there.
We'll put that back down.
OK.
Little intimidating, I know.
But once it starts
getting smaller,
you'll be able to see where
different parts come from.
To take the hind leg
off, what we usually do
is we'll look at where
the backbone starts
to curve into the
tail right down here.
Right on the inside, this right
here is where tenderloin is.
The tenderloin is
sometimes confused
with the loin,
which actually sits
on the outside of the backbone.
The tenderloin sits on the
inside of the backbone.
Much softer muscle.
And a lot of times, it's kind
of maligned as a flavorless cut.
And it isn't necessarily
true, you just
have to know what to do with it.
What we do is we brush it
with mustard and rosemary,
and we wrap it in panchetta,
which is pretty much the best
way to make anything taste good,
is we wrap it in panchetta.
AUDIENCE: Nothing goes
better with pork than--
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: More pork.
Exactly.
If there's a lily to be
gilded, we'll find it.
So we're just going to
follow that one cut.
And again, the same
principle all the way
back up to the backbone.
We'll take our saw.
[SAWING]
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: OK.
Sounds like we're through.
OK.
So now we've got hind leg,
shoulder, and our middle.
And at this point,
we've got all these ribs
here to contend with.
If we were cutting this in the
American way, what I would do
is I would split this
whole thing in half
and take the belly
away from the ribs,
or the belly away
from the loin, rather.
And this is when we get
spare ribs versus baby ribs.
At this point,
there's no such thing.
There's just ribs.
Spare ribs are the ones that
are connected to the belly.
They're a little bit wider.
A little bit tougher.
And those are the ones
that generally you
see done at barbecue
competitions,
because they're a little bit
harder to get from point A
to point B.
Whereas with baby backs,
you can just kind of
toss them on a hot grille and
wind up with something good.
But the mark of a good
barbecue guy or gal
is how well you
can do a spare rib.
We're not going
to be doing that.
What we are going
to be doing is we're
going to be taking each one of
these ribs out individually.
The reason we're going
to do that is, again,
to maximize the amount of
meat that we'll end up with
left behind.
Also, it's going
to leave behind all
these natural little
grooves in there that
are going to hold onto all
the garlic, and the salt,
and the orange zest,
and everything.
So let's get started.
So I'm working it
right against the bone.
We want to leave behind
as much meat as possible.
A little brute force
when necessary.
When in doubt.
So we're going to wind up taking
out each one of these ribs
individually.
The cool thing about these ribs
is that because of the fact
that you don't have all
the connective tissue
in between them, which
is the reason you need
to either braise them slowly,
or to smoke them really slowly
over a long period of time,
without that connective tissue
on there, and you can just
toss these onto a hot grille
or into a hot oven with
a quick marinade on them.
They've got a ton of flavor,
and they're a lot more tender.
Right down--
The guy that I learned how
to make this from in Italy
could do this in about
three minutes flat.
He was very fast.
And he would do it reciting
Dante the whole time too.
Pretty cool.
So I'm going to
turn this around.
That's one other
thing you always
want to keep in mind when taking
on some kind of big project
like this.
If something isn't
working out ergonomically,
you always want to
be able to twist
and turn it just so that
you're working in a way that's
most comfortable
and safe to you.
Does anyone have any
questions about any of this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What's the
story with [INAUDIBLE]?
So this is clearly not
refrigerated right now.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
Not right now.
AUDIENCE: How long can you
leave it out until it goes bad?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
About two hours.
Yeah.
Two hours.
Actually, the USDA
guidelines say four.
We're going to have this done
in about 45 minutes or so.
AUDIENCE: And then you
can put it back and--
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
That's correct.
Yeah, we're going
to get it seasoned.
And then we're going to
roll it up and tie it.
Then we're going to
go back in the fridge
and get it cooked off tomorrow.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You're
mentioning USDA reminded me
of a very popular
issue, what temperature
to cook fresh pork to.
Because I know you're
aware that the USDA has
a very high recommended
temperature.
But a lot of chefs these
days seem to prefer 141, 145.
What's your opinion?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
Well, the USDA actually
did just revisit that.
And they changed it to
145 for cooked pork.
You can take it to 160.
It depends on what
you're looking for.
With a pork loin roast, this guy
right here gets really tender.
If you overcook it, it gets
really tough really fast.
So we like to cook
that one to about 140.
With shoulder and leg, the
connective tissue in there
starts to break down at a
slightly higher temperature,
about 150.
And that's actually what
gives it the most flavor,
is when that connective
tissue starts to break down.
So with shoulder and leg,
I like to take them to 150.
Unless you're making
pulled pork, in which case
you want it to collapse.
And then we take it
to like, 181, 185.
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You've seen
a lot of prosciutto,
but not a lot of
other legs cured.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there
any particular
reason why we don't see like,
lamb prosciutto and goat
prosciutto?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
Some chefs make it.
The thing about lamb
and goat in particular
is that when you age that
fat, it gets a lot stronger.
So it's not to
everybody's taste.
Also pork, as you can see,
has the skin left on it.
Whereas with lamb, and
with beef, and with goat,
you can't leave the skin on
it because it will spoil.
And that skin, is it edible,
like it is with pork?
You don't get like
beef crackling or lamb
crackling, things like that.
So it's kind of a
stronger flavor.
And without that skin also,
when you dry cure something,
the skin acts like a
natural armor coating.
It keeps it from going
off, and it keeps them
from drying out too much also.
As a matter of fact,
when we make prosciutto,
and we got the skin on the
outside, this interior meat
part, after it's been
salted for about six months
or so, what we'll do is we'll
make a paste of rice flour
and lard, and rub that all over
the inside of the hind leg.
And that kind of mimics
what the skin does.
So it keeps it curing and
drying out on the inside,
but without getting too hard or
too dried out on the outside.
So I know people who are making
lamb and goat prosciutto.
It can be good.
It can be very, very
strong though too.
AUDIENCE: And I've also seen
prosciuttos that were skin on
and hair on?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Yeah.
That's wild boar prosciutto.
AUDIENCE: Is there any trick
to doing that sanitarily?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: No.
Well, the reason that we don't
make wild boar prosciutto much
in this country, at
least not commercially,
is we don't have the same
concentration of wild board
that they do like, in Italy.
You know, the cinghiale.
And there, they're
allowed to make it,
because it's a much
older practice.
Whereas here, our guidelines
are a bit different.
AUDIENCE: What about
at home for yourself?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: What
about just for home?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
Oh, you can definitely
do it at home by
yourself, for sure.
You need to make sure you
get a wild boar that's
big enough, for one thing.
Because if it's too small,
the salt to meat ratios
don't really work out so well.
And the reason that
they don't shave
those, the reason that they
don't take all that hair off,
is because with wild
pigs, the follicles
run a little bit
too deep in there
for them to be
able to scold them.
The way they get the hair off
of a commercially-bred pigs,
even if it's a pastured
pig like this one,
they put them in scolding tub
after they've been slaughtered.
And then they hang it up.
And they're able to just get
all that hair of with a planing
knife.
With a while boar, like I
said, the roots run too deep,
and they're not able
to get that off.
Usually what they'll
do in Italy is
they'll just shave the
skin off as they slice it.
And that's how
they sell it there.
It' good stuff.
Just it's rare to
see around here.
AUDIENCE: So as I understand
it, one of the potential risks
or pitfalls of home
charcuterie is botulism.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
That's correct.
AUDIENCE: But I'm just wondering
like, how legitimate of a risk
is that?
And from your practice, like,
do you guys inspect for that?
Or do you just assume that
you're preparation is so--
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: We do.
I'm sorry, go ahead, please.
AUDIENCE: No, that
was my question.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Yeah.
Botulism is
definitely a concern.
It's usually an issue
more with canned products.
And that's one of the
functions also of nitrates.
Nitrates will kill any
possibility of botulism
in the finished product.
So one teaspoon of, it's
called the curing mix.
It's mostly salt.
It's about 6% nitrate.
And then it's dyed
pink with beat juice
so that you don't accidentally
put a bunch into your scones
or something like that.
But there are many
different things
that can come up
with curing at home.
Which is why we
advocate starting small.
Starting with small batches
of smaller type salamis.
We wouldn't suggest to somebody
to start with a prosciutto.
Start with like, a
coppa, or a cacciatorini,
or a guanciale, or
something like that.
Something small.
And a lot of times also, you can
tell when something's gone off.
It won't look right,
it won't smell right,
and it won't taste right.
We've evolved with these
senses to tell us like, hey,
that's potentially dangerous.
So, yeah.
Using a small amount of
nitrate and practicing.
Just doing a little
bit at a time
is really the best
way to do that.
In a larger commercial
operation such as ours,
we're constantly
sending stuff out
to be tested or inspected
by four different agencies.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm just
curious, because I'm
really interested in
doing home charcuterie,
but I'm terrified of it as well.
Is there any kind of home test?
Or is just literally,
smells all right?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: I mean, yeah.
If it's nice bright red.
I mean, are you talking
about like, dry curing?
Something like that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: You want
to have the right environment.
We cover that a lot in our book.
Curing salt will
definitely help you.
Using enough salt.
And also, if you're
even slightly in doubt,
just toss it.
Or bring it by.
I'll take a look
at it at the shop.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Absolutely.
Does somebody else
have a question?
AUDIENCE: I have
like, 700 questions.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: OK.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: I'm kind of
star struck right now.
I preordered your book.
Gosh, I don't even
know where to start.
Do You do these types
of butchery classes
for the public?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
Every Saturday.
AUDIENCE: You do?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that in Napa?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Just in Napa.
Our kitchen in San Francisco
is a little bit too small.
But we have 12 person classes
with three instructors.
About three hours long.
And they include snacks,
and wine, and lunch,
and a big bag of goodies to
take home at the end of the day.
So, yeah.
Absolutely.
Yeah, that's one of my
favorite parts of the week,
is teaching classes
and meeting new people.
AUDIENCE: My friends are
going to be happy about that.
And my other question is,
what type-- I'm sorry,
I came in a little late.
What type of a pig is this?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
This a Berkshire hog,
which is also the Japanese
kind of [INAUDIBLE], what's
called a Kurobuta.
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: Kurobuta is the same?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Yes.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's same breed.
As I understand
it, it was a gift
given to the emperor by
a British ambassador.
And so, it's the same
breed, just different names.
AUDIENCE: Do you ever
cook with the wild boar
that we were talking
about earlier?
Because I have a friend
that hunts in Midland.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: OK.
In Texas?
AUDIENCE: No, no.
I'm sorry.
I think it's Midland near Napa.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: OK.
Oh, Middletown?
AUDIENCE: Middletown.
That's it.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: OK.
That place is lousy with them.
They're everywhere.
AUDIENCE: Really?
Is that good meat?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: It can be.
Yeah, it depends.
That's a lot more of
a seasonal product.
And it depends a lot
on the time of year
and what it's been eating,
and things like that.
So like wintertime, when
there's a lot to forage
and there's plenty of
moisture, and they're
really well-hydrated,
yeah, it can be great.
AUDIENCE: OK.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: OK.
So I've gotten all the ribs out.
What I'm going to
do now is I'm going
to move the tenderloin
over a little bit.
I'm going to take this whole
backbone out in one big piece.
First, I'm just going
to get rid of any blood
vessels and glands.
One of the things that we
emphasize a lot when we're
teaching our class is just
how little waste there really
is on a whole pig.
There's next to none.
So this is the tenderloin.
And ordinarily, if we wanted
to cook this on its own,
we'd just take the
whole thing out.
What we're going to do
instead, though, we're
just going to work right
around the backbone.
So, the whole thing will
come out in one fell swoop.
Great stock.
Ramen, broth-making.
All that fun stuff.
OK.
Get this [INAUDIBLE].
[SCRAPING]
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
How we doing, boss?
RYAN HARRIS: All set.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Nice.
AUDIENCE: What are
the best knives?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: I like
to use a good cheapie boning
knife that's not too flexible.
Forshner and Victorinox
are great ones.
They basically have
pretty much every knife
you could think of, from
cimeters, boning knives,
bread knives, chef knives.
All that fun stuff.
AUDIENCE: Quick question.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm also star
struck, by the way.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: You
all are too [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: My question
is economically
speaking, how much
does for a half--
if I were to go
want to get a pig,
generally speaking, how much?
Is it significantly
cheaper than buying it--
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: It would be
cheaper than buying it in cuts
absolutely.
Especially because, when
you buy it like this,
you're paying for the loin,
and the leg, and the shoulder.
It's all the same
price for a pound.
If you buy just the
loin, generally, it's
going to be like, twice as much.
So I think we sell a hog this
size for about $6 a pound,
whereas shoulder's usually
about $8, loin is about $13,
belly is about $9, and
hind leg is about $8.
This is about
180-pounder, so half of it
is going to be about 90 pounds.
It's $500 to $600.
RYAN HARRIS: We paid
$335 whole sale.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Oh, cool.
RYAN HARRIS: So if you guys
can wrap your head around that
a little bit, that
was $350 worth of pig.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Oh, yeah.
For something like this, for
a split, yeah, absolutely.
And I'm sure you can get the
Google wholesale price too.
[LAUGHTER]
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: And it
sounds like a lot off the top,
but when you consider
how much meat it is
and how much you're
going to get out of it,
this will keep you in
pig for a good long time.
RYAN HARRIS: Entertained
for a while too.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
Yeah, absolutely.
So what I'm doing right
now is I'm just taking out
the bottom of the breast plate.
You all notice sometimes
when you get ribs,
you get those little cartilage
end spits at the bottom?
They're super tasty?
That's what these guys
are right down here.
AUDIENCE: Somebody asked
about lamb prosciutto earlier.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I know Salumi in
Seattle does lamb prosciutto.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: They do.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I wanted to
ask you, they certainly
got a lot of national attention.
Are you big fans of theirs?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Of Salumi?
Yeah, absolutely.
Some of the stuff they
make is phenomenal.
You don't find too
much in the way
of competitive backbiting
in the salumi world.
There are so few of us,
and we all know each other.
And it's the kind of thing
that to do this for a living
and to be good at it enough so
that people will actually come
and buy what you're making,
we all know each other,
and we all compare
notes, and are
very supportive of each other.
And Armandino Batali
has been making
salumi for a really long time.
He's really good at it.
I was talking with Stephanie
about Bruce Aidells at lunch.
And we're really lucky to
have somebody like him.
He is an advocate, a teacher.
He's got great stories.
And he's just overall just been
a really, really supportive
and great guy.
So yeah, some of the stuff
that I've had from Salumi
is fantastic.
Like, I really like
the mole salami.
I haven't been able
to get up there.
But the things that
I have had from there
have been really, really good.
AUDIENCE: Have you ever
had their culatello?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: I have.
Yup.
And it's almost as good
as the Italian culatello.
Almost.
But that's a tall order.
OK.
So at this point, I've got
just about all the bones out.
So we need to get this left
little bit of shoulder blade.
This last little bit
of hind red bone.
And what we're
going to do next is
we're going to turn this over
and score the skin on it.
The reason we score the skin is
because if you don't do that,
you won't get crackling.
And you want crackling.
Crackling is very important
part of this roast.
So when we do it,
what I like to do
is turn the boning
knife upside down
and just use the
back of the knife.
You're just looking
to scratch it.
Because if you cut too deep,
what happens is as it cooks,
it expands.
And it's going to
open up, and you're
going to lose a ton of
fat and meat juices.
And really, the only
point of scoring
it is to allow the steam
somewhere to go, and to allow
some of that subcutaneous
fat to start rendering out.
So that's all you need to do.
You're just scratching.
I'm going to turn it back over.
Do you want start wrapping
some of these parts up?
Do you mind?
AUDIENCE: Is that loin
completely boneless?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Yes.
This is completely boneless.
Yeah.
You can just pop it
right over there.
Thanks.
So, yeah.
I'll just get in here and
check it out again real quick.
A couple little
pieces down here.
Thank you, sir.
AUDIENCE: How much
are the classes now?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: 175.
That's three hours.
It includes lunch, a bunch of
stuff to take home, recipe kit.
We also give a discount
on the day of class
too for people who take it.
So we like to think
it's a good value.
So that one last
little bit here.
AUDIENCE: Is the class
a hands-on class?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: It is.
It's as hands-on or as
hands-off as you want it to be.
Most the time, people
really want to get in there
and use the saw and
everything else.
Sometimes people are taking
it like, with their spouse
just to be supportive.
And they'll just hang back,
and take notes, and snack.
Exactly.
And take a lot of photos.
But yeah, they are hands-on.
But we don't grade,
and if people
don't want to get in there and
be hands-on, that's OK too.
We want it to be customized.
We want it to be fun, and
entertaining, and informative,
and as hands-on or hands-off
as people want it to be.
OK.
So let's start seasoning it.
One last little piece.
OK.
So the order in which
we're going to season this
is actually really important.
The reason being because
some of these ingredients,
we're going to really get in and
smear them on and massage them
in, whereas some are just
going to get kind of sprinkled.
So with that in mind,
we always do the garlic
and he orange zest
first, because we're
going to really be working
that in pretty good.
So the whole idea here is
that especially with something
like this, this is
about a 25-pound roast.
So you need to use
a lot of seasoning.
A lot, a lot, a lot.
It is.
It's kind of too
much of everything.
But they all prop
each other up so
that it's really well-balanced,
yet over the top.
And this roast is
one of the means that
was in that sandwich that made
for you all a little while ago.
It's called the Cuban.
Sounds like something
out of a spy novel.
Get me the Cuban.
AUDIENCE: Did you chop
the garlic and the zest
before you started grinding it?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: We
just mortar and pestle it.
I started it a little
bit so it wouldn't
go flying into the camera.
But normally, we just smash it.
Yeah.
And remember little pocket
where the shoulder blade was?
I want to make sure you
give that a little love.
All those little grooves in
between where the ribs were?
OK.
So next, there's
expertly zested orange.
You always want to use zest
because it has the most
oils, whereas juice
is very acidic,
and it can sometimes
denature the meat.
So instead of being
nice solid roast,
it'll kind of break it down.
Same idea with like, ceviche.
That's how it cooks the
meat, is by acidulating it.
So for this, you really
want to use this zest.
And these are kind
of fundamentals.
You can definitely
mix it up a bit.
If you've got a Meyer
lemon tree in your yard,
and you wanted to
use meyer lemon,
you could definitely do that.
You could use lime.
That's really strong, and you
want to be careful with it,
but you can definitely do it.
Orange, Seville
orange, blood orange.
Any of that.
All good.
So that's on there pretty good.
And now is the salt.
So this is where you really want
to channel your inner Thomas
Keller and go from really high
up, because the higher up you
go, the more evenly
it's going to disperse.
And you need to use a lot of it.
Keep in mind, this is
a big glorious roast.
And especially with
all the other goodies
we're going to be
putting on there,
you need it to have a
good amount of salt.
Don't neglect your pocket.
Gonna lift that bad boy up.
This is the skirt
steak by the way,
if you're all
familiar with that.
AUDIENCE: What type
of salt are you using?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: We
sea salt or kosher salt.
Whatever you like, the
most important thing
is that it's not iodized table
salt, because that's gross.
But we use Giusto's sea
salt, the local product.
Good stuff.
And you can buy it
in a 50-pound bag.
Which is good.
We use a lot of salt.
AUDIENCE: Would you
ever brine this?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
I wouldn't brine it,
just because it would
ruin your crackling.
You could definitely brine it.
I'm definitely pro-brining.
Especially when it
comes to leaner cuts.
A lot of times, we'll
take where this back half
or the tenderloin was, this is
where t-bone or porter house
chops come from.
We'll take those
chops, and we'll
brine them with a hard cider,
and sugar, and salt brine.
And then we'll cold smoke
them, so that basically, you
get like, a cold
smoked hard cider brand
pork chop that is just one of
the best things on the planet.
It's really good.
AUDIENCE: How do you feel
about injection brining?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Works.
Good stuff.
Absolutely.
You can definitely injection
brine something like this.
A lot of times,
we'll do that when
we dress up whole
pigs for people.
Because that way, for one thing,
finding a container big enough
to submerge them like this
is kind of challenging.
But especially with a really
big cut like that, hind leg,
you know, sometimes you put
a lot of salt on the outside,
but it still never quite
penetrates all the way
through to the bone.
So what we'll do is we'll season
the cavity with whatever spices
the client wants.
Generally, they want
porchetta seasoning.
But then, we will
take a little bit
of the garlic brine
or something else,
and we'll inject
just the thicker
parts of the whole pig for them.
And it helps keep it juicy too.
RYAN HARRIS: If you can't
get a hold of a middle
and you want to
brine your loin, you
can always buy loin with on
belly, brine the loin, brine
the belly, and you get
the best of both worlds.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Yeah.
And you still get
some skin on it too.
RYAN HARRIS: It doesn't quite
slice like the middle does.
AUDIENCE: Is there an ideal
cut to begin with for curing?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: For curing?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Yeah, like
I was saying, something small.
Guanciale is a really good one.
That's cured pork jowl.
That one cures really
well, because it's
got a very high fat content.
Its about 90%, whereas
like, pork belly's only 80%.
So it's just giving you an idea.
But it's really good, because
it doesn't take all that long.
And it also gives you a
lot of bang for your buck.
It doesn't take
that long to cure,
but you use it for
starting sauces, braises,
things like that.
If you're familiar
with carbonara,
like the sauce carbonara?
That's traditionally the cut
that's used for carbonara,
is guanciale.
Really popular in Rome.
You don't see a lot here.
But generally, we advocate
with just about everything
starting small, and working
your way up from there.
AUDIENCE: We used to get a
lot of smoked guanciale in LA.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Oh, yeah.
Face bacon.
So now, we're going to put a
little bit of Allspice on it.
And this one being
a bit strong, we're
not going to go
too crazy with it.
OK.
Then, cumin.
Cumin and fennel are cousins.
I don't know if
you all knew that.
AUDIENCE: Really?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: They are.
And at this point, you
want to kind of stop
seeing the color of the
meat, and go really crazy
with the amount of
spice that goes on here.
AUDIENCE: Do you
grind your own spices?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Yes.
Absolutely.
Yeah, we toast them and
grind them as we need them
and as we use them.
The only one we used
to buy ground was mace,
but then we found a supplier who
we could get whole mace from.
Have you ever seen whole mace?
It's really cool.
It's the outside
covering of a nutmeg.
Yeah.
And that's what mace is.
AUDIENCE: I thought
that was poison, though.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: I thought
that was poison.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Mace?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Well,
outside of nutmeg, I mean, I've
been using it for years.
[LAUGHTER]
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
Not that poisonous.
OK.
So that's about enough.
So now we're going to
do about equal parts
of sweet, smoked paprika
and hot smoked paprika.
I'm going to try not to do a
number on your carpet here.
It's nice.
If you don't like spicy, you can
use bittersweet or all sweet.
You don't have to use the hot.
AUDIENCE: Are there
curing or other techniques
that you can do in Europe,
but that for whatever reason,
the USDA or whatever
government body
doesn't permit you to
do in America that you
wish you could.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
That I wish I could--
we're allowed to do pretty
much anything we want to do,
with the exception
of what he was
talking about with wild boar.
But we really don't have enough
access to much wild boar here
anyway.
I mean, that would
be really cool.
Because at its best, wild
boar, it's a different beast.
It's kind of like
pork meets beef.
It's really, really super meaty.
But no, not that I can think of.
With good reason, there's a
lot of regulations surrounding
this, just to make sure that
the whole supply from start
to finish is safe.
And yeah, there are
a lot of regulations.
But they're for
everyone's benefit.
And it takes a lot of time
doing all the paperwork
and everything like that.
And we like to complain
about it a little,
bit because at heart,
we're cooks and butchers.
And we're into this for the
artisanal passion of it,
and not to necessarily be
logging times and temperatures
all day long.
But for the most part, no.
Once we can demonstrate
to our inspectors
that it's proven to
be safe, and that we
know what we're doing, that
we're keeping track of it
from start to finish,
we're pretty much safe.
If it's safe and people
like it, then go for it.
AUDIENCE: Why do you think
in Spain, if you walk just
walk down the streets, there's
just dozens of-- all the bars
have cured hams, and
here, it's such a rarity.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
Because nobody
loves ham like the Spaniards.
Nobody.
Their regulations are a
little bit more relaxed.
We wouldn't be able to keep them
out of refrigeration like that.
Whereas in Spain,
they cure their hams
enough so that it is a
truly shelf stable product.
Once that thing is
cured, and they cure them
for like, two years.
And the reason I say that nobody
loves ham like the Spaniards
is because they really don't
care about keeping enough
going so that the whole world
can have it whenever they want
it, and that they can
sell it for a cheap price.
They cure it until it's ready.
Whereas in Parma, and France,
and even here to a degree,
the impetus is to get it up,
and get it down, and get it out
into the world, so that
they can see a return on it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I don't know
how much market there
is in the US for
Spanish style ham
at up to 130 Euros per kilo.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Yeah.
The pata negra and
the Bellota-Bellota
is very expensive.
And that's the
reason behind it, is
because it's made from
really well-raised pigs that
are out there on
pasture eating acorns.
Some of the Spanish
producers, they'll
only use one side of the
pig, because the other side,
they constantly rub against
a tree and they scratch.
And they think that
that side is inferior.
There's a little bit of
superstition involved,
but that's valid.
OK.
Let me get all this extraneous
gear out of the way here.
Thanks.
And so now, we've got this huge,
glorious well-seasoned roast.
I'm going to roll this
bad boy up and tie it.
So, you usually want to
start from the loin side,
because you want the
belly to kind of be
wrapping around the outside.
OK.
We take our trusty
Fatted Calf brand
16 ply red and
white cotton twine.
And basically what
we're doing here
is we're making a slip knot.
So we're just going to make
a few knots, one at each end,
and one in the middle.
And then we're going to
go and fill in the gaps.
I'm doubling this over because
it's such a mighty cut,
that one length just
won't really do it.
This is going to take
me a few minutes,
so if anyone has any
questions, fire away.
AUDIENCE: Have you ever
worked with Mangalitsa before?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: I have.
My opinion is that
it's too warm in the US
to raise Mangalitsa really well.
The reason that it has all
that fur and that really thick
fat cap on it is because
it's native to Hungary,
and it gets cold.
It gets really,
really, really cold.
Yeah, I've had some
that's really tasty.
Honestly, it cost twice as much
as any other heritage pasture
raised pig.
And it's just not worth it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I know some of
Italian restaurants
were making a big deal
about it a few years ago.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: I think
it was kind of a good idea.
I think some things
are just best left
to where they were originated.
At some point soon,
there might be
a farmer who does
it really well.
They're temperamental.
And they take a lot
longer to get to weight.
Also, they have such
a high fat ratio,
that when you say you're
a farmer who sells that,
you're selling somebody 50% fat.
And you have to charge them
an astronomical fee for it.
It's a hard sell.
That's the long and short
of what I'm getting at.
What we prefer to use for
really fatty cuts like that
when we want to make like, lardo
or lonza, things like that,
we like to get Gloucester
Old Spot, which
is a British large breed.
They're very similar.
But the meat itself
is really good too.
And also, it's a
bit more available.
AUDIENCE: The last time I
heard, Wooly Pigs in in Spokane
still had a monopoly
on it I guess.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Well,
basically, that guy,
he had the only breeding
stock in this country.
And so when he would
sell piglets to people,
he would sell them
fixed, so that somebody
couldn't go and start
their own breeding program.
That's not really how
I like to operate.
But as you can tell from the
book, I'm not big on secrets.
If there's something
that I've learned,
I'd like to pass it along.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a reason you're only
coming from the rear side?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Oh, that's
just where I'm starting.
It's from years and years
of practice, I guess.
You can definitely start it
from the other side though.
For sure.
It's a secret.
AUDIENCE: What are some of your
favorite restaurants around
here?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Favorite
restaurants around here?
Like Southbank?
Or like, San Francisco?
I love La Ciccia.
Love, love, love La Ciccia.
It's a Sardinian place.
Mostly seafood.
Really, really wonderful family.
Unusual different food.
Great wine list.
I love Nopa.
You all had Laurence
here, right?
I think they do
an incredible job.
Where else do I really like?
I like the Chocolate Lab.
It's Recchuiti's place.
You know, the chocolate company?
They have a little cafe
that they started down
in the Dogpatch neighborhood
that's really good.
I don't get out much. [LAUGHS]
[LAUGHTER]
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Let's see.
If it's in a
tortilla, I'm into it.
I love, love some taco.
RYAN HARRIS: The Burritoeatery.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
Yeah, the Burritory.
Yeah.
A buddy of ours, a guy who was
working with us at The Fatted
Calf in Napa for awhile,
he started a truck.
It's Sonoran.
Sonoran burritos.
And the tortillas themselves,
we had some this morning.
They just unreal.
AUDIENCE: Is he
still up in Napa?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: He's
at Soma Street Food Park
every Thursday?
RYAN HARRIS: Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: OK.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: Any in San Francisco?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Yes.
Yeah.
The one right over
there by Trader Joe's.
AUDIENCE: You said on Thursdays?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday, apparently.
RYAN HARRIS: Yeah.
The hours vary each week.
It's on their website.
He's there every
Thursday, Friday.
And its always good.
AUDIENCE: It's Burritory.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Yeah.
Burritory.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You're emphasizing
most detailed use of the pig,
but are you [INAUDIBLE]?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
Yes, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: You didn't mention
Encanto when [INAUDIBLE].
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: I haven't
been there for a while,
to be honest with you.
It's very good.
But it's kind of like
a bus man's holiday.
When I go out to eat, I usually
don't go to pork temples.
But yeah, Encanto's very good.
AUDIENCE: They don't have
as much offal on the menu
as I'm sure Chris would like.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Yeah,
it can wear you down,
eating a lot a of that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] like
to sell more [INAUDIBLE]?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Well, he does
those fifth quarter dinners.
AUDIENCE: I had that once.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
How'd you like it?
AUDIENCE: Oh, we loved it.
It was my wife and
another couple.
And our waiter commented,
aren't you guys finished?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Well,
it's very rich stuff.
The way I like to use
offal is diced in tureens,
like as a garner, so you get
like, a little bit of it.
OK.
I think we're just about there.
So I'm going to
cut this in half.
I'm just going to
show you all what
it looks like on the inside.
OK.
And that's the Cuban.
A little boneless
Cuban pork roll.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: So how long
does that cure for?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: It's
best to let it cure,
or to sit with the
seasoning on it,
for-- I like to let it sit
for about two, three days.
AUDIENCE: And then you roast it?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
And then you roast it.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Yeah, because all
that seasoning,
it does wind up permeating
through the meat.
If we were to toss this in the
oven right now and carve it,
it'd be good.
But it's going to be
better after a couple days,
with all the salt--
AUDIENCE: And once you
roast it, how quickly
do you have sell it before it--
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Oh,
we sell it that day.
Yeah, yeah.
When we roast porchetta, as
soon as it's out of the oven,
we'll put it on the counter,
and we'll sell it by weight.
If there's any left
after a few hours,
we'll wrap it up,
refrigerate it, and turn it
into sandwiches the next day.
AUDIENCE: Is this actually
different than like,
a porchetta?
TAYLOR BOETTICHER:
The cut is the same,
but it's just the seasonings
that are different.
Yeah, I mean, we've done Korean
style ones with soy, and honey,
and ginger, and Korean chili
flake, and a normal coriander,
and cilantro.
That one's a lot of fun.
Again, there's Meyer lemon.
You could use lime.
You basically want like, a
balance of toasted spices,
citrus, garlic, a
good amount of salt,
and whatever else
you want in there.
But yeah, it definitely
is open to interpretation.
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
I'd like to thank you
guys for coming out today.
Taylor and Ryan.
Awesome job.
TAYLOR BOETTICHER: Thank
you so much for having us.
MALE SPEAKER: Beautiful.
Let's give them a
round of applause.